[Música]
bienvenidos a la cultura en modo casa
esta semana desde el hogar natural de la
pantalla admiramos las series y
miniseries de abril empezando por el
regreso de kate winslet si hace diez
años mildred pierce le brindó su primer
emmy que no le deparará met office town
también desvió son del género opuesto
pero en un solo episodio winslet deja
clara una soberbia actuación como
detective de un pueblo de pensilvania
que tras una desaparición sufre un
asesinato la gracia es que este arranque
criminal al uso no queda ahí sino que es
la base de un drama que condensa la
convivencia de esos sitios en los que
todos se conocen y saben los trapos
sucios de todos
yeimer por encima de resolver ese eje de
esas historias en las que ella misma es
un cuadro al ser abuela prematura con un
exmarido vecino a punto de casarse para
alegría de su entorno
ella siente presión por tener que ser
una heroína pero todo es realista en un
arquetipo policial
pero no
el file 20 we can medios
es antiguo explicación
en contrapartida discert en extensión
constante estrella real a netflix de
maravilla en los asesinos en serie pero
más que eso fue hechas obras de quien el
actor tahar rahim como se ve en los
rostros ha absorbido su carácter civil y
no la metamorfosis del franco-argelino
protagonista de mauritania no es total
es extremadamente difícil para mí porque
yo no tengo nada que ver con él quien
querría hacer este hombre es esa cosa
inconcebible en la que nos interesa
tanto que genera esta fascinación
repulsión pero para interpretarlo he
sufrido bastante teniendo que crear a mi
personaje desde el exterior el look la
manera de caminar de hablar esperando
que todo se reuniera en el interior y
crear algo hey que el cursus ese algo es
la vida del psicópata que los años 70 en
el sudeste asiático robó dinero y
falsificó los pasaportes de decenas de
jóvenes que seducidos por su habla los
embarcó hasta la muerte lo fuerte es que
este traficante de joyas
franco-vietnamita hoy encarcelado y en
su día prioridad de la interpol
sobrepasó todas ficciones de escaparse
cuatro veces
y ser perseguido por un diplomático
holandés y su esposa aunque le falta
ahondar en la naturaleza de alan como se
hacía llamar permite tratar a las
víctimas a sus cómplices y sin duda
frenar los de irnos de mochileros
es bonito
[Música]
no
a
dos grandes producciones rematan este
menú y no se adentran en lo literario
una es adobe en bonn del universo en
crisis a vis de la autora de jerusalén
life art hugo en la que se intenta
recrear la mitología que rodea a línea
estar con una joven huérfana que al
descubrir que tiene poderes se une a un
ejército de soldados mágicos un ambiente
de guerra con toques soviéticos en el
que verán que la lealtad trae consigo
sombras y luces en otro nivel está la
expectativa por la cuarta de the
handmaid's tale porque reprimir nuestra
es una ausencia de dos años no sin
muchos pointer se presenta como
temporada clímax con iun como enemiga
pública número uno e inspiración contra
el régimen patriarcal y religioso killer
la duda es a qué precio pagarán las
criadas y martha's en el golpe dado como
las perjudicará anserina y fred y como
la libertad podrá llegar al rol de
elisabeth moss
no
y ya se va y amsterdam
son momentos a veces
[Música]
estoy convencida de que margaret atwood
sería desde canadá la primera persona en
sumarse al robot que firma libros por la
pandemia es una tecnología en mitad
china mitad española en la que ha
permitido en barcelona- contar con
escritores como isabel allende y jonas
jonas on y hacer que lo internacional
llegue a cualquier fiesta del libro en
esta época tan especial no queremos
obviar que dos siglos de literatura
africana fueron arrasados por un
incendio forestal en ciudad del cabo
donde la biblioteca jagger contenía
65.000 volúmenes 26.000 folletos y 3.000
filmes
pero entre estas crisis con más motivo
animamos a leer y reivindicar las
librerías con novedades y reediciones
como las venas abiertas de américa
latina de eduardo galeano en su 50
aniversario o esta belleza ilustrada del
clásico de virginia wolf en 1928
respondió al nada fácil que necesitan
las mujeres para escribir obras su
solución que pasa por una independencia
económica y personal es aún razón de
lucha de ahí que el texto de
personalidad oral surgido de charlas y
con la mano y de elena medel y sara
morante sea importante de preservar para
las generaciones futuras
esta recordarán algún día que el primer
latinoamericano en dirigir una gran
ópera europea fue el venezolano gustavo
dudamel así estará durante al menos seis
temporadas de la ópera de parís tiempo
en el que el también músico y compositor
que ya en 2017 puede sentir la buscará
aumentar el repertorio siguiendo el
deseo de la institución de mayor
apertura y eso que dudamel cargará con
varios proyectos como el sistema de
orquestas juveniles de venezuela y la
filarmónica de los ángeles donde tiene
contrato hasta 2026 música como guinda
servida hoy por la rapera londinense en
little sins que además de lanzar cuarto
disco exhibe en el museo de historia
natural un precioso conjunto de
pensamientos sonoros félix sant jordi
como dicen en mi tierra y muchísimas
gracias
en south en el dobles billete
en el primer mundo porque llevo
el objetivo de compresión
[Música]
a mí